at the time deep learning was really
impressive in terms of these perception
tasks like vision you know speech so we
were thinking like could it be really
good at these other higher level tasks
like language so that's what we started
project turing and the idea was what if
we could do like an 10 deep learning
across the entire web to be able to
answer these questions you're listening
to the Microsoft Research podcast a show
that brings you closer to the cutting
edge of technology research and the
scientists behind it I'm your host
Gretchen using Rankin Majumder is the
partner group program manager of
Microsoft's search and AI and he has a
simple goal to make the world smarter
and more productive but nobody said
simple was easy so he and his team are
working on better and faster ways to
help you find the information you're
looking for anywhere you're looking for
it today Ragan talks about how three big
trends have changed the way Microsoft is
building and sharing AI stacks across
product groups he also tells us about
project turing an internal deep learning
moonshot that aims to harness the
resources of the web and bring the power
of deep learning to a search box near
you that and much more on this episode
of the Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
rankin Majumder welcome to the podcast
thank you it's great to be here so
you're a different kind of guest here in
the booth you're a partner group program
manager over in search nai at Microsoft
let's start by situating your group and
its work since you're not in microsoft
research per se but you do a lot of work
with the folks here how and where do you
roll up as they say yeah great question
so as you know the broader organization
is called Microsoft ai and research and
Microsoft Research is one of the
subgroups there so another sister team
of Microsoft Research is the Bing search
team and my group is actually search and
AI which is inside of Bing so we're a
sister team to Microsoft Research and
it's really great to be on this team
because what we get to do is work
closely with Microsoft researchers and
then productionize some of their great
research efforts put it into production
and then once we get to work at scale
and Bing we can actually go take that
technology and place it elsewhere like
in an office and dynamics and other
parts of Microsoft right so I'm getting
the visual of those nesting dolls
with each part going inside the other so
top big doll is Microsoft ai and
research correct and then Microsoft
Research is part of that right and Bing
is part of that that's right and then
your group search and AI is nested
within the Bing group that's correct
okay and who do you all roll up to Kevin
Scott who is our CTO I'm also EVP got it
all right well let's talk about what you
all do in search and AI and now that
we've situated you you have a
delightfully short but incredibly
ambitious mission statement tell us what
it is
and if you can what's your high level
strategy for making it real yeah so our
mission statement is to make the world
smarter and more productive and you'll
notice that our mission statement
doesn't just talk about search because
search is obviously the biggest thing
that we do but it's important to
understand what is the underlying user
need for why people are searching and
it's really to learn about something or
to get something done right so people
want to learn a lot about what's
happening with the coronavirus today so
that's
example of how our technology helps make
people smarter so you can know what's
going on in the world an example of
where we're helping make people
productive is something like when you
know I got my sink clog right so that's
something I want to learn really quickly
like how do i unclog my sink so that's
an example of productivity so the reason
you need to understand the underlying
user need versus like how they do it
today is the solutions actually change
over time so we want to be really close
to what is the user need that people
have and then our technology helps
provide that and satisfy that need as I
said the mission is about making the
world smarter more productive if we just
focused on the users on bing when you
still have a lot of impact but if you
look at the entire pie of customers from
Microsoft there's a lot more we can do
so that's why we've been working a lot
with office taking our AI technology and
not just bringing the Bing by bringing
into office so that's an example where
we increase the number of people we can
impact by like a billion there's a lot
more users using word and then if you
think about like as you're becoming you
know the world's computer so there's a
lot more impact we can have by bringing
our technology into Azure as well well
let's talk about what gets you up in the
morning in your role as a partner group
program manager for search and AI do you
have a personal mission or a personal
passion it's maybe a better way to put
it yeah well as any program manager your
goal is really to maximize product
market fit but my personal mission is
basically the same as my team's mission
which is really around making the world
smarter more productive and if you just
look at what's happening today which is
people are finding new ways to look for
information right 10 years ago is all
about search like people just kind of
typed in words but now people want to
find stuff more naturally like smart
assistants people just want to ask a
question you know in an ambient room and
get the answer people want to be able to
take a picture of a flower and say hey
what is this flower how do I take care
of this then the amount of information
is changing too so people aren't just
writing web pages like there were 10
years ago people are now taking pictures
uploading photos uploading videos so
going back to my example of you know how
do I unclog a sink I'm you don't just
want a web page walking through the
steps sometimes you want a video that
just shows you hey here's how I unclog a
so I think there's just a lot to do in
that mission and something that I feel
like we'll be doing for easily a decade
or more you know as you brought up the
flower and taking a picture of it I'm
thinking of this music app that I use
Shazam where you find out what a song is
I've often said I want Shazam for all
these different categories what's that
tree I don't even know what it is but if
I take a picture ever could you tell me
are you guys working on stuff like oh
we've actually shipped it already so if
you go install the being app you can
actually go take done this when I moved
into my new house like there were these
flowers like where these flowers would
look really interesting I can take a
picture of it and it tells you what it
is and then you can find out more
information so plants dogs those kinds
of things the Bing visual search app
does really well so go install today and
try it out well much of what we call AI
is still work in progress and there are
some fundamentally different ways of
doing AI within a company especially a
one as large as Microsoft so give us a
snapshot of how product groups have
traditionally approached building AI
stacks and then tell us some of the big
trends that you've noted in the science
of AI that have enabled the disruption
in that approach I think this is
probably the most exciting thing
happening at Microsoft at a so the way
we're doing AI is definitely
transforming if you think about how we
used to do AI maybe five years ago we
would have multiple different product
groups doing AI kind of independently
and for the most part didn't share
anything but there's three trends that
have really been changing that the first
trend is really around transfer learning
which is this concept that as you train
a model on one type of data and once
have a task you can actually reuse that
model for other tasks and it does
sometimes even better than it would if
you just trained it on that task
specific data the second one that's
happening is this trend with large pre
train models I think there's a couple of
these out there right like you've
probably heard about open a eyes GPT
Google has Bert Microsoft has this MTD
NN so you can take these models and just
train them on a bunch of data in a self
supervised way that it's called make it
very large and then you can actually
apply to lots of other tasks and it just
does phenomenal just to give you an
but like let's say the search team was
about a hundred people and they're
working on various parts to search all
the time so we did this took about ten
folks and said okay I want you guys to
look at these large transformer networks
and see what kind of impact could you
have so in just like a few months
they're able to ship an improvement so
large that it was larger than all the
other like ninety folks the all the work
they did combined so here were just like
shocked how important and how impactful
this kind of work was I'm so much that
at first we thought well does that mean
we don't need these other ninety folks
if you just work on these ten folks but
instead we really embraced it and we
said well let's get all hundred folks
working on these large transformer
networks and then the end like we just
had a wave of improvements over the last
six months of just like improvement
after improvement equally as impactful
as the one we had before so this is a
really big trend right now in these
large pre-trained models okay the third
trend is really around the culture of
Microsoft and how it's changing and this
really started with Society when he
became CEO he really has been focused on
changing the culture and making a lot
more collaborative in fact he's changed
incentive structure in the team so when
you're actually going through a
performance review it's not just about
you know what did you do but it's about
how did you use someone else's work or
how did you contribute to someone else's
work the other like person who's really
changed a lot is Kevin Scott our CTO so
he did a bunch of AI reviews and realize
like there's a lot of teams doing
similar stuff but some teams are a
little bit better than others so why
don't we do this work in a coordinated
way so when you take those three trends
together what we're doing is we're
starting to build this coordinated a I
stack across Microsoft where we have a
certain team saying look we are going to
build these really large NLP models for
the company not just ourselves because
the problem is if each team tried to do
that would be just way too costly and
then through transfer learning I can now
reuse this model in other parts so the
stack is kind of looking like this at
the very top you have applications like
being the different office apps you know
dynamics as your cognitive services the
layer underneath is a bunch of these pre
training models like we have one called
the Turing neural language
representation
we've got language generation we've got
these vision models the layer underneath
is these software systems which can
actually run these models really really
fast because the
models are very big and they're very
expensive so if you if you run them in a
naive way that we just like take too
long and you'd hurt the customer
experience so you need to actually do a
lot of software optimizations and then
the final layers are on the hardware so
that's around like CPU GPUs and we even
have our own little effort on chips with
FPGAs I want to talk a little bit about
four big areas you've identified as
important to progress in innovation in
search and AI and you've sort of labeled
them web search question answering
multimedia and platform so why are each
of these areas important especially as
it relates to the customer experience
and what innovations are you exploring
as you seek to improve that experience
yeah so I would say about five years ago
these things seemed pretty different
like web search question answering
multimedia and then the platform team
would sort of support all those teams
I've noticed and now you'll see it more
and more that these experience were very
integrated so if you go to Bing today
and you search for what do alligators
eat you'll see at the very top an answer
that says you know alligators eat things
like fish turtles birds but then you'll
also see an image there sort of fused in
with that answer because an image
actually helps you really get the
emotional part so just reading it is one
thing but humans also need that
emotional experience so by showing that
image right next to the answer it just
makes the answer come to life right so
that's one way where these things are
kind of related like the experience
putting them all together makes it much
better for the customer but also the
technology stacks are becoming very
similar too especially with deep
learning so with deep learning it's
mostly operating on vectors so the first
step in all of these systems whereas the
question-answering web search and
multimedia is really taking this corpus
of information and converting into
vectors using an encoder so that part is
pretty different for each one but then
once you have this corpus of vectors the
rest of the stack is very similar like
the first thing you do when a quarry
comes in is you do a vector search to
say alright what are the most similar
vectors here and then
you run cascade of different deep
learning models and each one gets
heavier and a little bit more costly and
that's what's been super interesting
where before each team had its own very
different stack but with deep learning
and everything just betting on this
vectors there's just a few services I
need to build really really well one is
this inference service which is you know
given some content vectorizer really
quick the other one is this vector
search service which is given a set of
vectors how do I search them extremely
fast your team has been involved in
achieving several impressive milestones
over the past five years so take us on a
little guided tour of that timeline and
tell us about the challenges you face
along with the rewards that you reap
when you try to bring research
milestones into production so first I
think a lot of the milestones I have to
give most of the credit to Microsoft
Research because they're the ones really
leading the way on pushing the
state-of-the-art on those benchmarks
like our team doesn't really focus too
much on the academic benchmarks so ever
since we went on this mission of let's
really push deep learning for NLP the
first academic data set that came out
that was really aligned with that
mission was by Stanford called the
Stanford question-answering data set
squad so it came out around 2016 and
Microsoft Research Asia was actually at
the top of the leaderboard like
throughout its existence so for the like
2016 2017 they kept building better and
better models until around 2018 they
actually achieved human parity which is
just a big milestone in general when you
have these academic benchmarks I think
that was like one of the most exciting
milestones around the natural language
space that we were able to achieve human
parity on this squad data set within two
years and then I think around 2018
another data set came out which is
conversational in question-answering a
year later 2019 once again Microsoft
Research Asia along with some other
folks and I think XD speech team was
able to achieve human parity on that
around the same time there was this Glu
benchmark which is also very interesting
but in Glu stands for general language
understanding benchmark so they had I
think 10 very different natural language
tasks so they thought well this is going
to be very hard if we can build one
model that can do well on all ten of
these that's going to be pretty
impressive and once again in a year
Microsoft Research was able to do that
so that's where they came up with this
MT DNN model which stands for multitask
deep neural networks oh
basically like in language Microsoft
Research has been doing a really awesome
job and while they're doing that our
team is just taking those models and
production izing them and what's
interesting is just because you do well
on academic tasks doesn't necessarily
mean it's really ready to be shipped
into production and the first big
learning was with the squad data set
which I talked about back in 2016-2018
so the model they used there was called
reading net or Arnett and we realized
that data set they had was a little bit
biased because every like the way this
data set works is you have a question
and you have like a passage and you're
basically trying to answer the question
but their entire deists that was
guaranteed that every question has an
answer but in a production context when
people are asking questions to the
search engine not every question has an
answer and in fact some questions
shouldn't be answered at all all right
so we need to actually also add
unanswerable questions well I want to
talk about a project that you've been
involved in called project Turing named
after the eponymous Alan Turing and you
call it your internal deep learning
moonshot which I loved what was the
motivation and inspiration behind that
project and what are some of the cool
products or product features that have
come out of that work yes a project
Turing was started about 2016 the
motivation for it was we're doing a
bunch of analysis on basically the types
of queries we were getting and there's
one segment that really stood out
because it was the fastest growing
segment of queries it was question
queries so people were no longer just
typing in keywords they were asking
questions to a search engine so like
instead of people typing in you know
fishing license they would say like
fishing age in Washington right what is
the fishing age in Washington when I
could go fish so we looked at that and
we thought well people just don't want
to click on a web page they just want
you to find the answer for them and then
many times the words that were in the
question and the words that were
actually in the answer we're very
different right so the previous approach
which was like let's just do keyword
matching was not going to work
we had to match a different level at the
semantic level so at the time deep
learning was really impressive in terms
of these perception tasks like vision
you know speech so we were thinking like
could it be really good at these other
higher level tasks like language so
that's what we started project turing
and the idea was what if we could do
like an 10 deep learning across the
entire web to be able to answer these
questions and it basically completely
change our search architecture to be
able to do this kind of thing and that's
why it was a moonshot so today
every time you issue a query were
running deep learning across basically
the entire web to get that answer and if
we didn't use deep learning we wouldn't
be able to answer a lot of these
questions because keyword matching just
wouldn't work so that actually is
happening now yes that's correct
okay that is happening and as we did it
there were all sorts of new innovations
that came out of it that we realize are
reusable for other parts of the company
and as we kept pushing the system we
noticed users kept asking harder and
harder questions so then we just have to
build better and better models so there
are a lot of interesting things that
came out of project turing so first was
we've got this deep learning search
stack a deep learning question answering
system but then we started to build
these turing neural language
representation and then just recently we
announced the turing nlg or natural
language generation so we realized many
times the passage itself can be kind of
long that comes from a web page so
sometimes we need to rewrite it and
shorten it for people so that's what we
started to look into the generation task
we were able to train one of the largest
deep learning language models and that's
called turing and LG announced that i
think last month right so it's very new
yes very new it's 17 billion parameters
it was like regressing 17 billion yes 17
billion my gosh yeah and just like three
years ago our biggest model is probably
ten million parameters so it just shows
you like how quickly the space is
growing okay so with that kind of
context where's the next number of
parameters are we going to hit a
trillion I mean is is this scaleable to
that level yeah that's a good question
so definitely we're gonna keep pushing
it because every time we get an order of
magnitude we notice they could just do
better
so we're not seeing it's slowing down so
as long as you get improvements I could
ship the customers we're gonna keep
pushing the boundaries but at the same
time we need to be more and more
efficient with our computation and also
just not chase something for Vanity's
sake right like just cuz you know we can
get to a hundred billion parameters
which we want to be able to do we also
need to make sure we're really
maximizing the value that the model is
actually getting with all those
parameters - I guess I should have said
a hundred billion before jumping to a
trillion it's like a triple dog dare
right after the dare you so drilling in
a little bit on these different
manifestations of your technology I know
that there's one called brainwave that
is part of the search experience now and
you had talked a little bit about the
fact that project touring and brainwave
were co-developed or concurrently
developed because they each had gaps
that they needed to fill tell our
listeners how touring and brainwave came
about together and how it speaks to the
importance of collaboration which you've
already referred to earlier on across
research and product boundaries yeah so
these really large deep learning models
are very expensive so they really
actually pushed both the software in the
hardware to its limits so while we're
trying to train these really big models
or even ship them to customers we need
to push the software and push the
hardware so brain wave the idea was they
could actually take deep learning models
and accelerate them really fast but they
really needed models that were worthy of
that kind of hardware right that they
spent a lot of time building this brain
wave compiler and we got all these FPGA
in our data center and when our models
were kind of small like 10 million
parameters I'm sure you can use
brainwave but it was just making
something that was already possible it's
a little bit faster it's like taking a
thoroughbred to a kid's party that's
right but it wasn't until we got to
these really large models like the
Turing an alarm model which was
you know 300 million parameters or even
600 million parameters and it was so big
if we tried to run it without any kind
of optimizations it would probably take
about 600 milliseconds and we would have
to run this multiple times for every
search so imagine you know you type in a
query hit enter and it took you like
five seconds to load the page alright so
this is something that was unacceptable
but we were getting these huge
improvements from it like I said before
it was the biggest improvements you were
getting right so imagine that we've got
this thing which we knew was excellent
for customers but we had no way to ship
it and that was the problem we had on
our modeling side and then on my
brain-wave team they're like I've got
this awesome hardware but I have no
really like big models pushing us so
that's how these two were kind of
co-developed so they needed something to
push their platform and the modeling
side of my team needed hardware that can
actually run these models so what ended
up happening is these models would take
600 milliseconds unoptimized we've got
it down to 5 milliseconds which is
blazing fast so the way to think about 5
milliseconds is the blink of an eye is
like you know 300 milliseconds so every
time you blink you know we're running
about like 50 inferences I think brain
image is one part of that hardware story
the other thing we've done is we partner
with Nvidia to be able to build faster
and faster ways to run inference on GPUs
so we actually open-source that in onyx
onyx runtime so if people want to reuse
our work they can just go download the
onyx runtime and the other thing we've
been able to do there's also part of
announcement in February is to train
that 17 billion parameter model we had
to do all sorts of things that weren't
done before because you can't fit this
model into GPUs right so we open-source
this library called deep speed is very
easy to use and it's just a great way to
train a really large model superfast
talk about what you've called the most
interesting story here something you
call the network effect what do you mean
by that and how does the network effect
make everything better
it's super interesting just the type of
collaboration we're getting so we train
a model once for a scenario and Bing and
that same models reused for lots of
scenarios in Bing lots of scenarios in
office so the economies of scale which
is you know each team can just easily
we get huge impact by just reusing
something somebody else did is really
transformative the second type of
network effect we're seeing is basically
by open sourcing this code like the onyx
runtime and deep speed and we also open
sourced our vector search code called SP
tag so by doing that other people can
now reuse the work but also contribute
to the work so it just keeps getting
better and better so that's something
you know our team really believes in
like if you open sourced something that
we think is state-of-the-art by other
people contribute to it it could
continue being the state of the art
right are you seeing this across the
industry that other companies are open
sourcing these really powerful
technologies in code yeah absolutely
that's one of the exciting things you
know Google open source tensorflow
they open source there Bert model
Facebook's open sourcing a lot of their
models they have pi torch which is open
source so it's really great that all
these AI companies and leaders are
actually open sourcing their technology
is anyone keeping their cards close to
their chest on any particular thing well
I mean you can never know for sure but
the general consensus is researchers
want to work in an open way you know the
old way of working an open way was just
publishing papers but now it's about
open sourcing so that's I think open
sourcing is the new like publishing
papers so they really want to share
their achievement and that's one way of
just proving that you can write a paper
but is that reproducible many times it's
not but if you open source it then
people can really test any no it really
works right well as much as I love
asking questions about the upside of
technological innovation I always have
to ask about the downside so now I'll
ask you Rankine is there anything about
the work you're doing that keeps you up
at night metaphorically and if so what
are you doing at the outset to help
mitigate it yeah definitely the thing
that worries me the most is around AI
and ethics so if you think about these
really large models they're trained on
existing data in a self supervised way
so they take the data all this text and
you know all this text that humans write
actually have biases all the existing
data out there has a bias and I think
Microsoft research even showed this in
one of their papers so if you look at
the word embedding for nurse
it tends to be closer to female mortem
bedding than the male weren't embedding
right so these models if they're just
trained on this already biased data
they're gonna learn that kind of bias
and that kind of stuff definitely
worries me in fact when we launched
Turing MLG we had a demo page for it and
we wanted to share the demo with
everybody but right before we did that I
gave it to a couple of folks on my team
or like hackers and I said hey why don't
you try to break this and within a
couple hours they came back and like you
know they could manipulate the model to
say like offensive things I just said
well if I just gave this to everybody
they could easily show examples where
this model was saying some things that
are inappropriate and then like just one
or two examples of it doing
inappropriate things would just wash
away all the good things I could do so
that's what we decided to release in a
control way but I think that's a really
important problem for the entire AI
commuted assault like how do we saw the
bias that we have in our data especially
when you're using these AI models to
make decisions that could affect
people's lives
alright so many many people that have
been in this booth have said the same
thing in terms of identifying the
problem and this is something we need to
think about and something we need to
talk about is anybody and maybe the
product site is the closest to you know
the reification of all of this is
anybody thinking about how you do that
how you let this out in a controlled way
and/or keep the bad actors from doing
their best work yeah obviously we have
to because we can't just let these
models out and do inappropriate things
especially when they show up in products
like being in office and so on so the
first thing we have to do is measure the
problem we have a lot of metrics to just
make sure that okay the
question-answering experience is not
saying offensive things right and it's
actually kind of tough because as the
models get smarter they get better at
finding answers and anywhere on the web
there's like somebody who's written some
garbage right so you can ask basically
fill in the blank like is so-and-so a
bad person and there will be somebody
out there who's written that right so we
actually first have to measure the thing
you don't want to accidentally do and I
think that's probably the first thing
around this space you have to do like
come up with some metrics around bias
and then once you have good metrics the
thing I've seen is teams are very good
at optimizing for them but it's still a
very hard problem see like how to even
measure bias how do you make sure that
you're measuring that all the sorts of
bias yeah this is going all the way up
to the c-suite Brad Smith is talking
about it in his book and it's a big deal
even in academic works is how you know
do you put out parental controls on a
product I use parental controls and yeah
quotation marks but you know that's
right and he has this ether committee
that our team is actually involved in
around just making sure like this AI we
were building make sure it can't be
harmful
it's using you know like a responsible
way and so on yeah so I think that's one
way I echo angle that I'm worried about
the second one is really around
inclusivity so if you look at all the AI
breakthroughs they're mostly coming from
a few companies they're you know
Microsoft Google Facebook some of the
Chinese companies like Alibaba and
that's because these really large models
take a lot of compute to go build so I
am worried that it's just going to be a
few companies that are just doing all
the AI breakthroughs so we really need
to think about how do we make it more
inclusive and I think the good news is
people are open sourcing a lot of their
technology so others can use it but when
it comes to compute and things like that
like there is only a few companies that
can afford that kind of stuff so we need
to also think about like how do we make
sure this AI transformation is inclusive
for as many people as possible well I
think you're starting to see that in
some of the AI for good efforts that
Microsoft is doing with you know these
grants that aren't just money but
they're compute resources right you can
use this and use Azure for free that's
absolutely right yeah so that's one way
to do that all right
tell us a bit about yourself where did
the high tech life begin for you and how
did you end up at Microsoft I guess the
high tech life started for me when I
went to Carnegie Mellon I study computer
science and computer
Engineering and while I was there I took
some machine learning courses and this
is early 2000 so machine learning wasn't
nearly as impressive it is today
but the time I was extremely fascinating
because I've always been interested in
these open-ended questions like the
meaning of life
how do people think is also one of those
open-ended questions that I was very
fascinated with so when I was learning
machine learning it's like well one way
to learn how people think is to kind of
rebuild it in machines and then I came
to Microsoft I started as a developer
for about four years then I switched to
program management and I also switched
the Bing team because at that point
while they're building up the search
team I realized this is the best place
to apply machine learning right so if I
wanted to really be at the cutting edge
of machine learning like this is the
place to be so and I've been there for
the last ten years just applying machine
learning to solve customer problems has
anyone ever tried to say come back to
academia and get an advanced degree yeah
definitely I'd say my parents know what
you're saying that because you know they
they think if you get a PhD just means
so much to you and family and so on I'm
like well I could but I'm having so much
fun here what's something interesting
that people might not know about you and
maybe it's a life event that impacted
your career or maybe it's a personality
trait that made you who you are today or
maybe it has no connection to any of
that and it's just an interesting data
point that we couldn't find out about
you if we typed your name into the Bing
box the thing that probably most people
would be surprised at first that you
can't find in the web is when I was
younger I got diagnosed with ADHD I was
getting trouble in school all the time I
wasn't like doing well and at one point
the teacher and the principal like
brought my parents in and they said hey
like you have to do something about him
otherwise like he won't be able to
return to school so my parents took me
to a therapist and then they diagnosed
me with ADHD and then they gave me some
drugs and it completely changed my life
because I started to like get the
highest grades in the class like I was
no longer getting to trouble it was so
strange I remember because my parents
noticed that my
behavior was different so they took me
off it for a little while and almost
immediately I started getting in trouble
again but one thing that was different
this time was I noticed it and I
realized well I don't like getting in
trouble like this is not fun for me so
then I actually made a conscious effort
to try and do well at school and not get
in trouble and I was able to kind of
make up for it so I really made an
effort to sort of control and change my
behavior as we close I'd like to circle
back to the beginning and sort of tie
things together if the big goal is to
make us smarter and more productive and
we're not there yet
what are the big open problems in the
fields that if solved would get us
closer to the big goal and what kinds of
people do we need to help us get there
so the first few things that you're
gonna see over the next year or two is
multimodal models so that's mixing text
images and videos together in a single
representation that's something we're
experimenting with today we're seeing
some good results so I think you'll be
able to like ask questions and get an
answer in images or in videos like look
inside a video look inside of the image
so I think that's going to be pretty
cool the other thing is like we're
definitely betting big on the steep
learning so you're gonna see us be more
and more efficient around how do we run
these models train them with less
compute how do we get more out of it
data efficiencies another thing like
given those limited amount of data how
do we make sure that we're maximizing it
to build better models but I'd say in
the long term the thing that is still
missing is like I think there's two AI
camps there's this deep learning camp
and then there's this what they call a
symbolist camp which is looking at
graphs and structured data I think there
still needs to be a way to fuse those
two so that you can actually take
unstructured data and reason over it the
way you can with structured data and you
can create new knowledge and things like
that because there's a lot of questions
we're seeing people ask and sure the
answer isn't written there but if you
combine the information and two
paragraphs you can actually get the
answer by combining them so I think
that's something we're still thinking
about it's not going to be an easy
problem but I think that's something the
academic field and industry still needs
to do
Bronwen majumder thank you so much for
joining us today it's been a real
pleasure thanks for having me to learn
more about Rankin Majumder and the
latest advances in search and AI
technology visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]